president Trump declaring a national
emergency over coronavirus in order to
expedite relief aid and testing to
States nearly 3,000 cases in 49 states
so far West Virginia is the only state
not reporting any cases of kovat 19 at
least 57 Americans have died as the
House passes a bipartisan aid package to
ease the economic fallout gentlemen
right now is coming from Devon Nunez he
is ranking member of the House Intel
committee he's also a member of the
House Ways and Means Committee and
compliment it's good to have you this
morning great to be with you Maria I
want to get into really your
investigation into China which goes back
years which you've I you and I have
spoken about it in the past but first
give us your take on the the
administration's response to current a
virus well most importantly I think what
American people have to understand is we
need to stop panicking here okay there's
no there's no shortage of food in this
country people don't need to go to the
store and fight over a bottled water or
toilet paper I come from the breadbasket
of the world right here in the San
Joaquin Valley we want people to go out
and buy food but there's no shortage of
food the the main thing that people need
to focus on it's just a couple issues
number one if you're sick at all be
smart stay away from people number two
if you know someone that is senior or if
you have an underlying health condition
especially with your lungs you are at
high risk so we need to focus all of our
energy on our senior population with
underlying health concerns
there is no reason maria for the
american people to be running to the
grocery store to buy 27 packs of toilet
paper okay there's no shortage of toilet
paper no shortage no shortage of food
okay and that's coming from someone who
we want you to buy food okay and all to
say this too I'll just say this too you
know we were just talking about the
economy and where there's a lot of
concerns with the economy here because
people are scared to go out but I will
just say one of the things you can do if
you're healthy you and your family it's
a great time to just go out go to a
local restaurant yeah likely you can get
in
easily there's you know let's not hurt
the working people in this country that
are relying on wages and tips to keep
their small business run to the don't
run to the I understood I just don't run
to the grocery store and buy you know
four thousand dollars of food my dick
don't go to your local local pub very
sympathetic to what's going on
particularly because it started in Wuhan
China but why is it that so many of
these diseases these sicknesses
originate in China what what is the
issue there well as you know we've been
looking at China for a very long time
the Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee and we're
actually building legislation now that's
based off of our investigation that
we've been conducting for a while so
look the Chinese they're a communist
dictatorship and I would just say it's
probably as easy as this to understand
you know they're inefficient okay they
can they can you know they have people
that we know are under authoritarian
control think about it the doctor that
actually was the whistleblower on this
ended up dead okay and if you look back
to what the Chinese did you know back
and they probably had this in the late
fall especially early winter they didn't
you know instead of like calling people
in and learning how to help and develop
an example a way for us to know how to
treat this they downplayed it